et les étudiants continuent leur
mobilisation contre la loi le projet de
loi du travail après les mouvements des
9 et 17 mars ils appelaient à se
rassembler à nouveau aujourd'hui à Paris
malgré la décision du gouvernement de
modifier certains articles polémiques
hier l'Union des étudiants communiste de
l'Université de Versailles saintquenttin
en Yveline tractait devant l'université
pour mobiliser à nouveau on écoute
Arnaud carbon secrétaire de l'US il
était au micro de Camille amambert il y
a eu quelques modifications qui ont été
faites néanmoins l'essentiel des des
réformes rétrogrades qu'elle comprend à
savoir la possibilité pour un patron de
diminuer arbitrairement le
salaire la possibilité d'augmenter le
temps de travail sans augmentation de
salaire la possibilité de radier les 11
heur de pause toutes les 24 heures de
travail tout ce qui fait enfin la
qualité rétrograde de cette de cette loi
est toujours présente et donc en fait
cette réforme enfin cette cette
relecture de la loi en fait n'est que ce
ne sont que des miettes de pain